ก็
สวัสดีค่ะครูเอ๋
ผู้หญิงสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนสวัสดีค่ะนัก
เรียน
หัวเราะ
ตกใจนะคะว่าซูมจะพูดว่ากำลังอัดแล้วนะ
หนังครูคู๋ค่ะอ่ะโอเคถามก่อนได้ค่ะผู้
หญิงถามได้ค่ะผู้หญิงเขียนล่ะกูเออรู้
แล้ววันอะไรกูอีกวันนี้วันอะไรคะวันสี
เขียววันพุธค่ะค่ะวันพุธวันที่เท่าไหร่คะ
วันพุธทุกวันที่เท่าไหร่อ่ะผู้หญิง
เก๋คุย
หรือวันที่ 1 แล้วไงเดือนอะไรคะเดือน
มิถุนายน
ปีพตมีอะไรคะต้องขั้น
ติดกันลืมเขียนก่อนนะเขียนช้าปีคศอะไรคะ
2022 ใหญ่กว่าเหตุสอบอันนี้นะคะตอนนี้
เวลากี่โมงคะครูเอ๋เวลา
03:00 น 03:00 ไหมผู้เขียนจะได้เขียนของ
คนไทยบ่าย 3 โมงกี่นาทีให้คุณเอ๋ 5-10
นาที
3:50 น
3:00 นนาทีเย้เก๋เรามีนักเรียนกี่คน
เล่าเรียน
13 คนแล้วค่ะ
โอ้ว 13 คนนะคะใช่เราร้องคนที่ 14
24 นะคนที่ 14 มานะคะก็คอมเม้นท์ขอเป็น
คนที่ 14 นะคะถ่ายค่ะๆครูเอ๋คะคุยมีคำถาม
ข้อที่ 1 ถามครูเอ๋ถามผู้ a ค่ะ 3 คู๋คู่
หญิงกับครูเอ๋ชอบถามเนาะตายค่ะถามว่าอะไร
คะถามว่าที่กรุงเทพครูเอ๋อยู่กรุงเทพฯใช่
ไหมคะใช่ค่ะกูเอออยู่กรุงเทพเนี่ยพี่เอ๋
อยู่บ้าน
หรือว่าอยู่
Condominium  Apartment
rooms  a อยู่ Condominium
3 ขอคุยอยู่ Condominium ไงไอ้
ตัวอยู่ที่ผู้หญิงทีแล้ว
เอาแล้วก็คอนโดมิเนียมคู๋เนี่ยมีถนนไหมคะ
อ่ะ
ที่อยู่ในซอยมีค่าคู่หญิงไม่ได้ที่ว่ายนะ
ไปแล้วคอนโดมิเนียมคู๋ต้องจ่ายถนนแล้วก็
เข้าซอยไปนะคะค่ะ
ซอยซอยโหแต่ไม่บอกนะถนนอะไรอะไรนะคะไม่
บอกนะถนนอะไร
บอกได้
ครูเอ๋อยู่ถนนอะไรคะสุขุมวิท
โอเคสุขุมวิท
ยาวมากๆ
สุขุมวิทที่ 5  500 กิโลเมตรนะผู้หญิงใคร
ค่ะนักเรียนไม่รู้ก็กู whitney ขี่หรอก
เป็นร้อยร้อยหาน่าจะร้อยร้อยกิโลเมตร
ไม่รู้กี่ร้อยกิโลเมตรตั้งแต่
กรุงเทพฯสมุทรปราการชลบุรีระยอง
หูยานลพบุรีถึงกัมพูชาแม้แต่ณถนนสุขุมวิท
ครูเอ๋อยู่ที่ถนนสุขุมวิท
วันนี้เนี่ยนะคะครูหญิงน่ะก็จะมีคำถาม
เกี่ยวกับ
แถวๆบ้านครูเอ๋งวดแถวบ้านก็คือ
บ้านบ้านอยู่ตรงนี้ใช่ไหมคะบ้านที่นี่
ข่าวบ้านก็คือรอบๆตรงนี้ใช่ไหมคะใช่ค่ะ
รอบบ้านครูเอ๋
เราก็จะพูดว่าแถวบ้านพร้อมบ้านโอเคป่ะ
เจ้าแถวบ้านครูเอ๋รอบบ้านครูเอ๋เนี่ยหรือ
ว่าบ้านครูเอ๋เนี่ยอยู่ใกล้กับอะไรบ้าง
มีอะไรบ้างนะคะมี
รูปแรกค่ะครูเอ๋โอ้
ข้างเหรอคะไงค่ะหาง
แถวๆบ้านครูเอ๋เอ๋มีมาห้างไหมคะมีคุณแถว
บ้านคือกูเอกเดินไปได้ล่ะคะไม่ใช่ขับรถ 30
นาทีอันนี้ไม่ใช่แถวบ้าน
มีค่ะครูหญิงหูมีแต่ว่าเล็กๆนะคะหาดเด็ก
เล็กๆไม่ใช่ห้างใหญ่ห้างเล็กมีห้างรู้
เหศักดิ์บ้านครูเอ๋เอ๋แล้วก็เดินไปห้าง
ใช้เวลาเท่าไหร่คะง้อจักบ้านบ้านที่บ้าน
ใช่ไหมคะเกินไปห้างใช้เวลาประมาณ
5 นาที
อันนี้ใกล้นะใกล้ก็
คิดครึ่งกิโลเมตร
ใช่พอใกล้ค่ะน่าจะประมาณ 50 มพี่ปุ้ยไม่
ใช่
วิ่งกิโลเมตร 500 เมตร
500 เมตร 500 เมตรฉัน
จะไม่ถึง 500 อ่ะ
ประมาณรมาน่ะกูจะไม่ถึง 500 เมตรนะคะค่ะ
นี้ก็เดินเดินเดิน 5 นาทีคือครูเอ๋เดิน
เดินช้าๆโอเคเดินช้าๆยังไงคะ
โอ๋เดินน่ะ
เวลาพูดเอกเดินค่อยๆเดินเดินช้าๆเขวเดิน
ช้าๆเนี่ยใช้เวลาเดิน 5 นาที
แล้วเธอเดินเร็วๆ
ไม่เคยไม่เดิน
ถ้าเดินเร็วๆรถ
ถ้างั้นงั้นก็ขอรู้แล้วถ้านัดเรียนเดิน
อาจจะ
ถึง 5 นาที
สวัสดิ์น่าจะ 3 นาทีใกล้ใกล้บ้านครูเอ๋
มากๆค่ะไม่ไกลหาขาใกล้ไกลอะนี่ใกล้นะคะ
ค่ะเพราะว่าถ้าไกลก็คือแถวบ้านครูเอกก็
ไม่มีห้างสมัยทักไกล
อ่ะต่อไปค่ะคะมี
อันนี้ค่ะครูเอรู้ไหมเขาว่าที่นี่คือที่
ไหนตลาดมี๋
คนไฟเรียกอะไรค่ะครูเอ๋
ซุปเปอร์มาเก็ตนักเรียนสมัยเล็กคนไทยไว้
พูดตลาดมีแอร์นะคะนักเรียนผู้หญิง
คนไทยก็พูด
ซุปเปอร์มาร์เก็ตนายไอซ์ก็ได้ไม่พูดเปอร์
มาเก็ตทคืออะไรอ่ะ Super  Super หรือคน
ไทยพูดโลตัสนะคะถ้าทั้งหมดโลตัส
ก็มี Big  C นะก็บางครั้งก็พูดโลตัสก็ได้
อ๋อ
แต่ก็พูด Big  C เน้อบิ๊กซีโลตัสบิ๊กซี
เป็นห้างอ่ะโลตัสเป็นซุปเปอร์รอไม่เหมือน
กันหรอหรือบิ๊กซีแบบซุปเปอร์มาร์เก็ตผู้
หญิงคิดบิ๊กซีเป็นซุปเปอร์มาร์เก็ตแต่ก็
ได้ยินบางคนบอกบิ๊กซีเป็นห้างทางก็คืออัน
นี้นะนี่คือข้างเนี้ยห้างมาหาค่ะอันนี้
ซุปเปอร์มาร์เก็ตวัดซุปเปอร์มาร์เก็ต
เนี่ยเขาก็จะมีรถเข็นใช้ส่วนใหญ่เลยนะคะ
อะไรก็ซื้อผัดสมัยซื้อผลไม้
ซื้อของมาซื้อยาสระผม
ซุปเปอร์มาร์เก็ตครูเอ๋คะอะไรคะแถวๆบ้าน
ครูเอ๋เนี่ยมี
ใช่มั้ยคะแถวบ้านกูอีกแล้วครับมีค่ะมี
ซุปเปอร์มาเก็ตจริงมีแล้วจะบ้านครูเอ๋
เดินไปซุปเปอร์มาร์เก็ตใช้เวลาเท่าไหร่คะ
นาทีหวันเอาแปลว่าซุปเปอร์มาร์เก็ตกับ
ห้างอยู่ใกล้กันเหรอครูเอ๋ไอ้กันค่ะ
ครูเอ๋เดิน 5 นาที
นักเรียนเดินน้อยกว่าน้อยกว่าน้อยกว่า
นาทีผู้หญิงเดิน 5 นาทีเหมือนครูเอ๋ค่ะ
หรืออาจจะมากกว่า
มากกว่าจะเดินฤดูดูวิวมีเราก็ดูก็จะใช้
เวลามากกว่านะคะแล้วครูเอ๋ไป
ซุปเปอร์มาร์เก็ตแถวบ้านบ่อยไหมคะอ่า
3 วันหรือ 4 วัน
หนึ่งครั้งคุณแม่อ๋อ 3 วัน 4 วันเนี่ยไป
หนึ่งครั้งถ้างั้นก็
คุยก็ประมาณเนาะประมาณ 2 ครั้งต่ออาทิตย์
หนูต่อสัปดาห์ก็ประมาณ 2
[เพลง]
โอเคมีอีกยก kuai ไม่ได้ถามกูหญิงแหละขอ
แค่อยากจะถามเขาแรกด้วยไหมคะใครไวๆไม่มี
เวลาอยากใกล้บ้านครูหญิงมีซุปเปอร์มาเก็ต
ไหมคะมีค่า
นี้แล้วครูหญิงไปซุปเปอร์มาร์เก็ตใช้เวลา
เท่าไหร่น้องแต่ของผู้หญิงและไกลกว่าครู
เอ๋ผู้หญิงเดินประมาณ 10 นาที
หรอ
Big  C  Big  C บิ๊กซีซูเปอร์ก็ไม่รู้
ดิ Big  C ค่ะแถวบ้านผู้หญิง Big  C นะ
ครูเอ๋
เหรอนักเรียนครูเอ๋ไปบ้านครูหญิงบ่อยๆไม่
เห็น
ซุปเปอร์มาร์เก็ตมีเอ๋บ้านผู้หญิงดีดี BTS
BTS  2 ครูเอ๋ลงบีทีเอส 2 แล้วก็มาบ้าน
ครูหญิงบิ๊กซีอยู่ตรงนี้ขอ
เอกก็เลยไม่ค่อย Super  Pi สายสายๆมีค่ะ
มีบิ๊กซีแต่เดินนานกว่าครูเอ๋
เข้าใจเข้าใจก็ไปค่ะครูเอ๋อันนี้กูเห็น
น่าจะชอบนะคะชอบมาก
ที่นี่คืออะที่ไหนคะครูเอ๋ตลาดค่ะตายก็
อาจจะขาย
พาต้าหรอแล้วก็มีมีตลาดที่ขายเนื้อสัตว์
ค่ะเนื้อสัตว์น้ำครูเอ๋คะ
ใส่ค่ะก็จะมีไก่ขอโทษค่ะเยอะมากเลยนะ
เนี่ยมีไก่มีปลาอ่ะค่ะลา
มีเยอะๆแล้วแถวบ้านครูเอ๋มีตลาดในคะ
มีค่ะมีก็คือ a ถ้ากูเองจะไปตลาดใช้เวลา
เดินกี่นาทีอ่ะไกลนิดหน่อยนะเดินนะคะเดิน
เดินเดินน่าจะประมาณ
20-25 นาทีโอโอ้
คู๋เดินไหมคะ
มอเตอร์ไซค์
มอเตอร์ไซค์กี่นาที
5 นาทีมอเตอร์ไซค์
ถ้าเราออกไปนะคะเออผู้หญิงนี่ก็
มอเตอร์ไซค์ดีก็ใกล้นะถ้ามอเตอร์ไซค์ 5
นาทีแต่ถ้าวันไหนคืออยากจะเดินคู่เอกคิด
ออกวันนี้เดินคุยก็เดินเดินๆก็ประมาณยี่
สิบนาทีไปถึงตลาดค่ะ
นะต่อไปหน้าบ้านผู้หญิง
ไม่มีโอมี
เอาตอกอเหรอได้ไอ้อาร์มมีค่ะแถวบ้านครู
หญิงดีแต่ไม่ได้ขายมีขายทั้งหมดมีไหมมี
น้องเนื้อสัตว์มีผักใจค่ะแต่ว่าถ้าเดิน
ก็น่าจะพอพอๆกับตลาดแถวบ้านครูเอ๋
เดินได้เดินได้แต่ใช้เวลานานๆวิ่งก็
แท็กซี่ไม่มอเตอร์ไซค์นะคะอ่ะและมีอีกค่ะ
ครูเอ๋อะไรให้คิดมากในรูปนี้เนี่ยที่ไหน
คะ
โรงแรมในโรงแรมนะคะแถวบ้านครูเอ๋เอ๋มีโรง
แรมไหมคะมีค่ะงูมีกี่โรงแรม
ที่ครูเห็นน่ะครูเห็นนะคะแล้วใกล้เลยนะ
เอาใกล้เลยนะเดินได้เลยหน่อยนะคะอ่ะ 2
โรงแรมค่ะโอโห้เดินกี่นาทีอ่ะ 3 นาที
ใกล้มากครูเอ๋เดิน 3 นาที
ให้
นักเรียนเดิน 1 นาทีถ้าจากบ้านข้างหน้านะ
ข้างหน้าข้างหน้าคอนโดแล้วก็เดินเดินเดิน
ก็โอเคโรงแรมเลี้ยวซ้ายเลี้ยวซ้ายณโรงแรม
เลี้ยวซ้ายอ้อแล้วก็ข้างหน้าอันนี้คอนโด
กูเองนะคะหน้าก็โรงแรม
โรงแรม 2 ที่ใช่ไหมคะแล้วใส่โรงรอมาแล้ว
ดีไหม
ok  ok ดูหน้าเข้าใจแล้วค่ะไม่ต้องพูด
เลยอาหารอร่อยโอเคก็โอเค
ปรับๆต่อไปค่ะเกรดคิดว่าในรูปอะนี่ไม่ใช่
ประเทศไทยนะค่ะแต่ว่าเป็นสถานที่เหมือน
กัน
ที่ไหนก็ไม่รู้สถานที่นี้คือโรงเรียน
งานนายโรงเรียนถ้าประเทศไทยก็ต้องมีธงซาด
ไทยคุยกูไอ้ว่านให้ได้ค่ะอุ้ยสีแดงอะมี
สีแดงสีแดงแล้วก็
สีน้ำเงินสีน้ำเงินอยู่ตรงกลาง
แล้วก็สีขาวค่ะอันนี้ธงประเทศไทยได้ค่ะ
นี้ก็จะเป็นโรงเรียนไทยโรงเรียนไทยเคริ่
คะแถวบ้านครูเอ๋มีโรงเรียนไหมคะมีค่า
มีกี่โรงเรียนงั้นไม่ถามว่ากี่โรงเรียน
ตัวเองตัวเห็นมีมีแต่คณะมีมีหนึ่งแล้วก็
มี 2 มี 3
มี 4 ได้มั้งโห
มีมีโรงเรียน
เดินไปได้ก็ใช้เวลาประมาณ 20 แม่ชีค่ะ
เดินประมาณ 20 นาทีอ่ะยี่สิบยี่สิบยี่สิบ
ห้าค่ะพอๆกับตลาดใช่ไหม 20-25 นาทีใกล้ๆ
ตลาดขอ
[เพลง]
ถ้าเราไม่ได้เป็นสปอนเซอร์เรานะคะตัวเอง
ไม่เป็นไรไหม
พูดเล่นเนี่ยตู้ a คะแถวๆบ้านครูเอ๋เอ๋มี
โรงพยาบาลไหมคะ
ใกล้เลยหรอคะใครที่กูเอกเดินไปได้
เดินไปได้ไม่มีเอาไม่มีแถวบ้านกูเองไม่มี
โรงพยาบาลจริงๆก็เดินได้นะ
เดินแต่น่าจะเดินประมาณ
กี่นาที
50 นาที
นี่ไม่ใช่ใกล้แล้วไม่แถวบ้านแล้ว xxx ไวๆ
นะไม่กล้า
kansai เนาะมากกว่าครึ่งชั่วโมงนั้นมาก
กว่า 30 นาที
แต่ถ้านั่งรถล่ะครูเอ๋นั่งรถถ้า BTS ก็
ประมาณ 6 นาที
ก็ก็ถือว่าใกล้อยู่นะฮะ BTS  6 นาทีคือ
ครูเอ๋เดินอ่ะอาจจะ 50 นาทีแต่ว่าถ้าคน
ที่ขาขาขายาวเดินเร็วๆก็อาจจะครึ่ง
ชั่วโมง
[เพลง]
โอเคนะก็แถวบ้านได้แต่ว่าไกลหน่อยหนึ่ง
แถวบ้านแตกไหล่น่าจะประมาณ
33 กิโลเมตร
ใกล้ไหม
3 กิโลเมตรไม่ไม่ไม่ใกล้แต่ว่าว่ามีก็
คิดว่ามันก็อยู่แถวบ้านเราไหมหาแถวบ้าน
ไม่ใกล้ไม่ไกล
ไม่ไกลๆสัตว์โรงพยาบาลนี้ไกลตายโรงพยาบาล
กรุงเทพฯไม่ได้อยู่แถวบ้านครูเอ๋เอ๋ไม่
ได้อยู่แถวบ้านครูหญิงนารายณ์แต่คู่เอก
เข้าไป
ทรายกับครูหญิงเนี่ยมีโรงพยาบาลอยู่แถว
บ้านไม่ไปพี่
เริญ 10 เดิน 10 นาทีถึง
แต่ไม่ไปนะคะไม่ไปแต่ว่าเป็นกรุ๊ปเดียว
กันนะคะบีดีเอ็มเอสเหมือนกัน
มีอีกค่ะกูเองตามที่ต่อไปที่ไหนคะครูเอ๋
อะไรนะดับเครื่องฮางไทยดับเพลิง
จ่ายสถานีดับเพลิงแถวบ้านครูเอ๋อะไรครับ
พี่เอกได้ค่ะผู้หญิงนักเรียนไม่เข้าใจ
เพลิงเอ้าทำไมไม่เข้าใจนักเรียน
บีกินเนอร์นะ
กินเข้าใจนักเรียนไม่ต้องเรียนนะเองสถานี
ดับเพลิง
ทำอะไรค่ะมีไฟไหม้อ้าวไฟไหม้ตรงรถแล้วจะ
ทำอะไร
ถ้ามีนี่มีตรงไหนอะมีหมู่บ้าน
แล้วก็ก็มี
ไปไม่หา
หน้าไฟไม่ปลื้ม
ร้อน
โทรศัพท์สถานีดับเพลิงสถานีเขาก็จะมีรถ
แล้วก็กลับมาปีเบาะหวอ
ก็ใช่ค่ะรถดับเพลิงจะมีเสียงวอลโว่ไม่รู้
นักเรียนได้ยินไหมซุ้มตัดหรือเปล่า
เสียงเปล่าวอ
สายหายจะได้อยู่ค่ะเอาโอ้นี่คือสถานที่
ของสถานีดับเพลิงมาจะมีน้ำเนาะเขาก็จะทาน
มีท่อแล้วสนามจ่ายเนาะน้ำจากรถเนี่ยนะคะ
อ่ะก็ดับเพลิงนะคะตายเพลิงระบบเพลิงไหม้
ดับเพลิง
ทรายครูเอ๋คะแถวบ้านครูเอ๋มีสถานีดับ
เพลิงไหมคะมีค่ะถ้าคุยตอบว่าไม่มีผู้หญิง
ก็แบบนี้มี
เดินกี่นาทีครูเอ๋น่าจะ
ประมาณ
8 นาทีนคู๋ 10 นาที 15 นาทีขอคุยเอาว่า
10-15 นาที
สถานีดับเพลิงกับถึงสถานีดับเพลิงนะคะน่า
รักมีอีกค่ะครูเอกสถานที่ต่อไปอะไรค่ะเอา
สถานที่ต่อไปที่ไหนคะครูเอ๋
สถานีตำรวจทำไมคุยเหตุทำหน้าแบบนั้นล่ะ
เอกกำลังคุณ
ครูหญิงอยากจะหาตำรวจนิประเทศไทยไงคะเป็น
สถานีตำรวจประเทศไทยนักเรียนก็ประเทศนัก
เรียนอาจจะไม่เหมือนกันค่ะเก๋คะแถวบ้าน
ครูเอ๋มีสถานีตำรวจไหมอันนี้ค่ะตำรวจ
มีค่ะมีมีนี้เดินกี่นาที
เดินประมาณ
15-20 นาที
ก็โอเคนะ 15-20 นาที
ครูเอ๋เคยเดิน
เดินผ่านสถานีตำรวจแถวบ้านไหมคะที่เคย
เดินผ่านไงกูเอกก็เลยลืม
โอเคไม่ได้ไปใช่ไหมคะไม่ได้ไปเข้าสถานี
ตำรวจไม่หิวข้าวค่ะจันทร์วิ่งก็ไม่เคย
เข้านะครับไปชอบเข้าใช่ไม่มีคนชอบเนาะ
สถานที่ต่อไปค่ะเราไม่ถึงเข้าหน้าบ้านไม่
ชอบกับไม่มีคนชอบณสถานที่ทำรู้กัน
สถานที่ต่อไปค่ะครูเอ๋รู้ไหมสถานทิพย์ไร้
สนิมออกไปรษณีย์
แม่เราทำอะไรครับไรษณีย์ก็เรามีของ
แบ่งเช่นถ้ามีหนังสือ
อยากจะส่งให้เพื่อนค่ะหรือมีเขียนจดหมาย
สวัสดีครูหญิงสบายดีไหมน้องหญิงไลน์เหรอ
คะตัวเองเมื่อก่อนอ๋อ
เราไปจดไปรษณีย์สายส่งจดหมายอย่าหายนะคะ
ส่งของที่เป็นกล่องค่ะไงแถวบ้านครูเอ๋
เอ๋มีไปรษณีย์ไหมคะเอาไปรษณีย์นะคะอ๋อ
มีเล็กๆอ้ะก็ได้ถ้าเป็นไปรษณีย์ก็มีเป็น
ไปรษณีย์
ในห้างไอ้ในซุปเปอร์ค่ะก็มี
ใช่ค่ะโอเคโอเค
จริงๆมีไปรษณีย์ในซุปเปอร์แล้วก็
ขอโทษที 1  1 กิโลเมตรมีไปรษณีย์ใหญ่ๆโอ๋
ไปรษณีย์ใหญ่ๆแบบในรูปใช่ไหมคะแบบในรูป
ค่ะก็ถือว่าแถวๆบ้านนะคะ 1 กิโลเมตรไม่
ไกลมากเดินประมาณ 30 นาทีค่ะมีไปรษณีย์
ค่ะค่ะ
โอเคสถานที่ต่อไปค่ะครูเอ๋
พี่ปุ้ย
อะที่ไหนคะในรูปเนี่ยโรงหนังแรงหนังแถว
บ้านครูเอ๋มีโรงหนังไหมคะมีค่ะหมอเดินกี่
นาทีลงหนังณโรงหนัง 5 นาทีขึ้น
ประมาณ 8 นาทีถึง 10 นาที
น้อง 8 ถึง 10 นาทีค่ะ
ครูเอ๋ได้ไปดูหนังที่โรงหนังแถวบ้านไหม
เมื่อก่อนไปดูบ่อยๆดีไหมคะโรงหนังแถวบ้าน
ครูเอ๋โอเคค่ะ
แต่ตอนนี้ไม่ได้ดู 2 ปีขึ้น
ทำไมทำไมไม่ได้ดูหนัง 2 ปีครึ่ง
เขาปิดจะเอาใช้ห้าม
ห้ามดูหนังนอนนี้เปิดแต่ครูเอ๋กลัว
เข้าใจ
อ่ะมีอีกครั้งเอกสถานที่ไม่รู้ไหมที่นี่
ที่ไหนเอ่อร้านขายรูปค่ะใช่ค่ะร้านถ่าย
รูป
แล้วตอนนี้ก็พูด Studio
ใช่ค่ะเพราะว่าร้านถ่ายรูปบางร้านก็เป็น
แค่ร้านถ่ายรูปธรรมดาวีซ่า
พาสปอร์ตร้านถ่ายรูปมีอะไรบ้างคะเนี่ยมี
กล้องถ่ายรูปค่ะแล้วก็อันนี้เราเรียกไฟ
สตูดิโอค่ะอันนี้ก็สปอร์ตไลท์ไม่พูดเอ๋
ใช่ใช่แล้วก็ฉากนะเนี่ยเราเรียกว่าฉากนะ
คะแล้วก็เสาร์อ่ะ
วันเสาร์ทราย
อันนี้ขาตั้งกล้องค่ะอันนี้ขามขายตั้งไฟ
sudio เนาะอ่าบังแล้วก็สายไฟค่ะนักเรียน
จะบอกภาพเมื่อก่อนไม่บอกมีอะไรแล้วแต่แต่
ครูนักเรียนกล้วยคะประวัติคลิปนี้เราเอา
สถานที่วัดสภาเรียงอะไรแง่ครูเอ๋คะแถว
บ้านครูเอ๋มีร้านถ่ายรูปหรือว่ามีสตูดิโอ
โอถ่ายรูปไหมคะนี่ไหมอ่ะ
มีไหม
ครูเอ๋
ไม่รู้
แตะคิดว่ามีอ่ะ
ในห้างนี้ไหม
ในข้างไม่มี
ในซุปเปอร์ไม่มีมี
แต่ถ้าเดินเดินไปประมาณ 20 นาที
ยี่สิบนาทีครูเอ๋เห็นมีร้านแล้วก็มีชุด
ชุดสวยๆ
สำหรับแปลนแต้มเล่นๆดูดิโอถ่ายรูปแต่งงาน
ภาพแต่งงาน
คิดว่ามีเนาะจ่ายอะไรก็เป็นสตูดิโอวีดีโอ
ถ่ายรูปแต่งงานค่ะแล้วถ้าเป็นวีดีโออา
ร้านถ่ายรูปที่ว่าร้านถ่ายรูปม้าอะไม่
เห็นนะคะตัวเองยังไม่เห็นแต่บางทีมีนะคะ
แต่ถ้าเป็น Shop เล็กๆนี่ค่ะค่ะสอบเล็กๆ
ที่เป็นร้านถ่ายรูปเหรอค่ะที่ BTS มีอ๋อ
เออใช่ๆพอถ่ายรูป
และเร็วใช่ไหมถ่ายรูปเร็วๆถ้าเป็นแบบ
เนี้ยเป็นร้านถ่ายรูปใหญ่ๆไม่เห็น
her ลาย V หนึ่งที่แล้วกันนะคะครูเอ๋
ผู้หญิงสมัยนี้เรียกว่า
สถานีรถไฟสายสถานีรถไฟแต่ไม่ใช่รถไฟ BTS
นะคะสถานีรถไฟอ่ะที่เป็นรถไฟแล้วก็ไปภาค
เหนือ
ไปภาคอีสานในประเทศไทย
ไปภาคใต้เป็นรถไฟไปเชียงใหม่
รถไฟไปภูเก็ต
ปัดไปไปชลบุรีด้วยผู้หญิงมีด้วยหรอมี
ไม่รู้เลยแล้วแถวบ้านครูเอ๋มีสถานีรถไฟ
ไหมคะก็มีค่ะไม่มี
เข็มบ้านเปลี่ยนเว้นท์ย้ายบ้านตั้งแต่
ชลบุรีก็เลยลืม
ไปเส้นตะวันออกแต่งชลบุรีนี่อันนี้นะ
ผ่านเฉยๆไม่ได้จอดขายที่กรุงเทพฯนะคะแล้ว
ก็ไปชลบุรี
แต่แถวบ้านเครย์ไม่มีสถานีรถไฟ
ไม่มีค่ะไม่มีน้องก็ไม่รู้ว่าแถวบ้านนัก
เรียนเนี่ยมีสถานที่อะไรบ้างที่อยู่ใกล้ๆ
เนาะเดินไปได้ไม่นานนะคะก็คอมเม้นท์ทั้ง
ล่างนะคะว่ามีอะไร
ใส่ค่ะแต่ว่าวีดีโอนี้ก็หมดเวลาแล้วนะคะ
เดี๋ยวเราเจอกันใหม่ในวีดีโอหน้าก็อ๋อเค
OK สวัสดีค่ะบ๊ายบาย